the arrival of stinger Kang's new
fashion sense and a familiar looking
Cantina the Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania trailer was filled with
Easter eggs you might have missed
forget about saving the universe
scotline's greatest accomplishments are
the victories he Encounters in his
everyday life for example in Ant-Man and
the WASP his daughter gives him a
world's greatest grandma trophy which at
the time was the best birthday present
Scott ever received however that
Accolade pales in comparison to being
hailed as one of the best workers to
ever grace the ice cream industry the
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
trailer notes that Scott is
Baskin-Robbins employee of the century
and that's in addition to being an
ex-con successful podcaster and member
of The Avengers he even stops buying his
Ant-Man suit to accept the award showing
just how far he's come since his days of
being down on his luck it's great to see
that super heroism hasn't made Scott
forget about his days working in an ice
cream parlor furthermore the trailer
also reveals that Dale will be part of
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania as one
scene shows Scott shaking hands with his
old manager
the Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
trailer doesn't explain specifically how
the Ant-Man family gets sucked into the
quantum realm we can only assume that
it's because the film's primary villain
Kang the Conqueror somehow uses Cassie's
new tech for his own schemes throughout
the trailer Janet seems terrified of
anything relating to the quantum realm
saying that there's some information she
didn't share with everyone else there's
something I never told you the trailer
makes it seem like she's talking about
Kang who looks to be in control down
there or at least has a very imposing
presence could Kang be the reason why
everyone's in the quantum realm is he
chasing after Janet for something she
did there did Cassie's technology
somehow awaken him MCU fans will
remember that Ant-Man and the WASP
revealed that Janet spent 30 years in
the quantum realm before Scott rescued
her there's no telling what kind of
trouble she got into during that time
but Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
will definitely give us some answers
the clue was in the title as to where
Scott and hope would spend their next
adventure but now the new trailer
confirms that they're not the only ones
headed to the quantum realm after
Cassie's Quantum satellite apparently
makes contact with all the wrong people
all of ant-man's allies are pulled along
with him into a strange new world it's a
secret universe
from here the trailer lays on the
stunning and surreal vistas of the
quantum realm pretty thick this latest
installment of ant-man's story feels
less like it's pulled off of a comic
book page but instead from a classic
science fiction movie involving another
small Adventure this could very well be
Scott Lang's own Fantastic Voyage the
classic 1966 film with a group of
explorers shrunk to microscopic size who
traversed the insides of a living human
body while there doesn't seem to be any
human test subject in the area when
they're shrunk down quantumania seems to
match the epic adventure on a tiny scale
one shot suggests that when they arrive
the group ends up scattered across this
unknown territory this could lead to
some father-daughter time with Scott and
Cassie and hope getting the opportunity
to know the mother she thought she lost
forever
it's hard to ignore the fact that a bar
scene during our Peak into the quantum
realm as the trailer plays out feels
like a visual callback to the Star Wars
saga the circular half bar it's
multi-armed Bartender and the
well-packed room definitely harkened
back to the most Eisley Cantina the bar
in the trailer seems to have more of an
air of sophistication that most Eisley
lacks but several patrons are seen
wearing brown cloaks reminiscent of
Obi-Wan Kenobi and his brother J Luke
Skywalker The earth-toned Outfits feel
like a callback to the Empire and many
of the characters seen within the
establishment resemble the rubber-faced
puppets of the sci-fi classic in Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania however there's
a lot more neon involved and the
lighting is generally warmer in tone
there are also what appear to be strange
hookahs sitting on several of the tables
fans will have to wait to see how these
devices and the bar itself will be used
in the film
Cassie is one of the most significant
reveals in the Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania trailer she shows her dad
the device she helped make which
communicates with the quantum realm
after the group is sucked into the realm
we see Cassie in her regular street
clothes with her dad eventually toward
the end of the trailer we see Scott hope
and Cassie all in special suits as they
stare down someone off screen while
we've seen Scott in Hope suits before
Cassie's is new it looks like we might
see Cassie take on the mantle of stature
in the third Ant-Man flick we first saw
poster art of Cassie's purple suit at
San Diego Comic-Con 2022 and now it's
finally a reality in the comic stature
makes her debut in 2006's Young Avengers
number two and later becomes stinger in
2016's astonishing Ant-Man number six
Cassie's powers are very much like that
of Scots but they can often be connected
to her emotions it seems like Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania will introduce
us to a new MCU hero who could appear in
future films
all it took was a scene stealing
monologue in Loki and blurry camera
footage from d23 to get fans hyped about
Jonathan Major's next take on Kang an
outstanding performance was always
guaranteed but the fact that this
appearance would potentially be
completely different from what we had
before was even more exciting it only
takes a few seconds to confirm that this
Kang isn't quite as jovial as the one
before and he might have some plans for
Conquest
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man in the trailer we first get a
good look at him in his iconic get up
from the comics which originates from
the 40th Century from there the
Conqueror to be is shown having a brief
chat with Scott with Kang coming off as
far more threatening than the jokey
Anarchist we met before our only
questions are how Scott will hold off
against this new and unknown threat and
will The Joint help of Cassie and hope
be enough to ensure that the Kang
Dynasty is held off for as long as
possible
[Music]